[Music]
hi welcome to the emperor show
you guys this is the only late night
show that's written by six humans and
one pony
we're coming to you tonight from studio
8g in rockefeller center with a live
studio audience
everyone in our audience is vaccinated
and everyone in our audience is wearing
a mask and everyone in our audience has
one dark secret that i will guess by the
end of this show
in addition to a studio audience we also
have a terry davis
derek say hi to the audience hi audience
lou
yeah and guess who else is here tonight
my real life sister angie
yay
angie came all the way here just to see
me
don't nobody want to see you
i came to see tarik
hi tarek
hi angie stop it you guys cut it out
folks it's been a crazy week in america
let's find out what happened
after participating in the capitol riots
the so-called qnan shaman was sentenced
this week to 41 months in prison he was
judged by a jury of his peers
even they were like
is it the way
you look when you're getting dry because
we have a baby i like it when white
supremacists face consequences nope
before being itis yeah
sang a song by that title i don't regret
it before being sentenced this week over
his participation in the capital riots
the so-called q anon shaman reportedly
quoted the film the shawshank redemption
and so did the judge when he said guilty
north korean leader kim jong-un this
week made his first public appearance in
over a month even crazier it was in
people magazine
what are the criteria i don't you tell
me i mean
six tornadoes touched down last weekend
on long island and this lady didn't tell
nobody
i feel like she should have sent her i
sent the text oh she did she sent texts
it's those nails she can't really hit
the yes i did watch that show and i'm
sorry
since the year 2000 the international
space station has reportedly been
boarded by just seven black people but
that's because no one ever answers the
question who all gonna be there
[Applause]
a man from washington dc recently moved
his 70 000 piece collection of darth
vader memorabilia to texas and also his
one piece collection of condoms
[Laughter]
[Applause]
never removed from packaging
[Music]
singer taylor swift recently released a
10-minute version of her song all too
well that story again
sometimes you need kanye to interrupt
[Applause]
and finally
candy brand reese's unveiled a pie sized
version of its peanut butter cup this
week and less than two hours later they
were completely sold out they were all
bought by this person
and that was the monologue did you like
the monologue
yes
i bet you did hey
hey angie angie did you like the
monologue
not enough tarik oh yeah you're right
i'm sorry i need you to go home i don't
like you
okay now you guys because i have my own
show i have a responsibility to say
things that people need to know
that aren't being said
it's a cool opportunity that i don't
take lightly there are very big
obvious truths that no one wants to say
on tv but i will
now just a few minutes before we started
taping the show kyle rittenhouse the man
accused of shooting three people during
a black lives matter protest was
declared
not guilty on all charges so
i can't believe i have to say this but
it's not okay
for a man
to grab a rifle
travel across state lines
and shoot three people and then walk
free
it's not okay for the judicial system to
be blatantly and obviously stacked
against people of color
it's not okay
for there to be an entirely different
set of rules
for white people
but uh i don't care about kyle
rittenhouse i don't care about that
racist judge and i don't care about how
that jury must be
white people have been getting away with
murder since time began i don't care
about that i care about you
and uh i can't believe i have to say
this but you matter
you matter every time one of these
verdicts come out
it's easy to feel like you don't but i'm
here to tell you
that you do you matter
you matter so much that the second you
start to get a sense that you do a man
will grab a gun he shouldn't have in the
first place and travel all the way to
another state just to quiet you that's
the power you have
so don't forget it
now i just needed to say that so let's
all take a deep breath
and do some
ridiculous [ __ ]
you guys
i wish i had a fake steering wheel so i
could pull it out and go
we're gonna take a hard left into crazy
town
crash
okay do i look pink faced
no i know i look pretty good
you guys
you guys thanksgiving is next week which
means we're just a few days away from
one of the most magical experiences new
york city has to offer
the annual lighting of the rockefeller
center christmas wall-e
that's right
i know
beautiful
now you may be thinking to yourself
isn't that amber's cue card guy but he's
not he's the rockefeller center
christmas wally and he's the crown jewel
of the holiday season in new york
standing nearly six feet tall the
rockefeller center christmas wall-e was
hand-picked by a team of experts who
scoured the country in search of the
most beautiful verdant and majestic
christmas wall-e they can find
[Music]
[Applause]
after being selected the christmas wally
was transported overnight on a flatbed
from his home in new jersey
to his new home right here at
rockefeller center but the real magic
happens on december 1st when the
rockefeller center christmas wally will
be illuminated in front of millions of
tourists
after spending days wrapping our
christmas wall-e and strings of colorful
lights and tinsel a team of technicians
will put the finishing touches on the
festive display
[Music]
and of
course the rockefeller center christmas
while he wouldn't be complete without
the fiesta resistance a 900 pound 15
million dollar swarovski crystal star
which will be lowered on top of wally
this month in a moment of holiday
triumph
it will truly be a breathtaking event
but
unfortunately for us here at the amber
ruffin show we're going to miss all of
that because we'll be on hiatus during
the ceremony now it's a major bummer but
short of a christmas miracle there's no
way we'll ever get to see wally fully
lit up
wait what was that
oh my god
illuminated the christmas wall-e
it's a christmas miracle
wow
amber do i get to stand here for the
rest of the year bringing joy to
everyone who believes in the magic of
christmas no man you still got a whole
cue cards oh yeah right
thank you let's go hup watch out for
that star wars i got it watch out i got
it don't you hurt yourself you still
have to do the cards from the ground all
right
now
a lot of things have happened in america
this week it seems like every time i
checked the news there was another huge
story but aaron burr told me tonight
that she wants to take a moment to talk
about one of the more important news
stories of the week and she wants to do
it in a very special way
[Music]
on that great proud morning the sun
arose and shown a brand new
light and finally there was
illumination on just what's wrong and
right
the bells rang out and the sweet sweet
sound reminds us we are strong
the notes of those bells reach the
heavens and maybe freedom was their song
and will it out of cry from the dance of
our souls from sea to shining sea
all our countrymen rejoice
cause britney is free
what i know britney's brief after 13
long years the judge finally ruled the
ender conservatorship wait
that's what this song is about you bet
it is you said you were going to do a
song about one of the biggest news
stories and that's what you're getting
baby
[Music]
no one ever said that life is fair
everybody's gotta take a hit
you get knocked down and you get back up
and yell i've had enough of it
so the next time you think you can't get
it done remember brittany and persevere
[Music]
feel it loud enough for the whole
britney army to hear let it stir up the
joy within the hearts of lovers
like you and me
[Music]
all our countrymen rejoice cause britney
is free
so
nothing about the climate summit or the
infrastructure bill this is like a
billion times more important
brittany's conservatorship is more
important than the infrastructure bill
thank you i'm glad someone said it
amber i think you're getting carried
away tarik have you ever been held
monetarily hostage for years and years
and then one day you were freed
no
okay well let me see if i can explain it
[Music]
b is for miss spears herself ours for
her ego she
because everybody knows
please end this
terry
is she not a great performer did she not
dance her ass off with a whole giant
snake at the vmas for your amusement
you never shouted the words to her music
at karaoke from memory
yeah but all those albums all those hits
tarik
did britney spears not move you
oh my god
she did
b-r-i-t-n-d-y
be
[Applause]
another vegas
presidency
and we'll all line up to get tickets
and she'll actually get paid
by those tickets
just freaking and we'll buy
tickets cause britney
britney is free
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you